[Música]
el presidente de estados unidos joe
biden informó al mundo que murió el jefe
de al qaeda ayman al-zawahiri durante un
ataque con avión no tripulado en
afganistán el mandatario señaló que la
noticia de reparación a las víctimas del
11-s
el presidente de méxico andrés manuel
lópez obrador ex propio más de un millón
de metros cuadrados de territorio
privado para abrir paso al tramo 5 del
tren maya son en total 36 inmuebles que
serán ocupados inmediatamente tenemos
información desde ciudad de mexico
y el juicio por presunta corrupción en
contra de la vicepresidenta argentina
cristina fernández entra ahora en la
etapa de alegatos la ex mandataria
acusada de asociación ilícita para
defraudar al estado cuando fue
gobernante entre 2007 y 2015 nos cuenta
nuestro corresponsal en buenos aires'
estas son las noticias de américa en
francés 24 o comenzamos con este
informativo o koné de las noticias más
destacadas murió el jefe de al qaeda
ayman al-zawahiri como consecuencia de
un ataque con aviones no tripulados de
la agencia de inteligencia
estadounidense en afganistán se trata
del mayor golpe para el grupo extremista
desde que su fundador osama bin laden
fue asesinado en 2011 la ofensiva
sucedió en la capital de kabul el sábado
el presidente de eeuu joe biden dijo que
el régimen talibán tenía conocimiento de
la presencia de zawahiri en el
territorio afgano y agregó que su muerte
trajo cierre a los familiares de las
víctimas del 11 de septiembre escuchemos
sus palabras
el sábado bajo mi dirección
eeuu llevó a cabo con éxito un ataque
aéreo en kabul afganistán que mató al
líder de al-qaeda
ayman al-zawahiri era el líder de osama
bin laden estaba con él todo el tiempo
era su número 2 en el momento del ataque
del 11 de septiembre y estuvo muy
involucrado en la planeación del 11 de
septiembre
este martes se cansa se decidirá si
continúa protegiendo el aborto en su
legislación estatal o si por el
contrario y como demandan los
legisladores republicanos permite que
los diputados regulen sus prohibiciones
sin que la justicia se oponga es la
primera vez en 50 años que la ciudadanía
de un estado estadounidense decide sobre
esta cuestión aunque las opiniones están
divididas lo que ocurra allí será un
termómetro a escala federal martha
moyano es amplia
kansas se prepara para tomarle el pulso
al aborto este martes este estado
estadounidense de cerca de tres millones
de habitantes vota para decidir si sigue
protegiendo el derecho al aborto en su
constitución estatal o si por el
contrario se permite a los legisladores
regular sobre esta cuestión sin
injerencia de la justicia hasta el
momento la participación temprana indica
un aumento de la movilización respecto a
los comicios estatales de 2018
creo que la votación temprana hasta esta
mañana era de cerca de 2000 personas más
que en el 2018 también tenemos unas mil
personas más que solicitaron su boleta
electoral que hace cuatro años así que
definitivamente tenemos un repunte en el
registro de votantes y de gente que sale
ejercer su derecho y porción adoptivo en
la actualidad kansas permite interrumpir
los embarazos hasta la semana 20 de
gestación pero obliga a que las mujeres
se sometan a un asesoramiento y un
período de espera de 24 horas antes de
practicarse lo para algunos esto debe
cambiar ya
es el aborto es picado es quitar una
vida si la gente quiere ser promiscua y
acaba quedando embarazada
este resultado del pecado la comitiva no
necesitan cometer un segundo pecado
el voto es el primero en eeuu después de
la derogación de la sentencia de roe
versus wade que protegía este derecho a
escala federal
los activistas a favor del aborto en
kansas han llegado francamente un poco
tarde a organizarse creo que mucha gente
quizás dio por sentado el derecho al
aborto aunque han ganado algo de terreno
será interesante ver lo que ocurre no
creo que nadie tenga una idea sólida de
cuál será el resultado de lo que ocurre
en kansas era sin duda un termómetro de
la situación del país respecto al aborto
a escasos cuatro meses de las elecciones
de mitad de mandato vamos a méxico el
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador
hizo oficial la expropiación de un
millón no de 93 mil 118 metros cuadrados
en 4 municipios todo esto para la
construcción del tramo 5 del tren maya
nuestro corresponsal en ciudad de méxico
mario carbonell nos contó qué pasará con
los dueños de estas propiedades
y se ha publicado este decreto para
expropiar estos predios y las
instalaciones que hay adentro de ellos y
es algo que no tiene marcha atrás el
decreto señala que la secretaria de
desarrollo agrario territorial y urbano
comenzará a tomar posesión de estos
terrenos y nada podrá detenerlos los
propietarios de estos terrenos tendrán
diez días hábiles para poder enfocar
pero únicamente la cantidad con la que
van a ser indemnizados por esta
expropiación ya el gobierno hará las
requisiciones a la secretaria de
hacienda para contar con estos montos
para indemnizar a los dueños de estos
predios pero es algo que ya se considera
de utilidad pública y a partir de que
entra en vigor este decreto es decir a
partir de mañana mismo podrá el gobierno
tomar esta de estos terrenos
el tráfico de personas es un fenómeno
que crece en la frontera entre eeuu y
méxico una práctica peligrosa que ha
acabado con la vida de emigrantes como
aquellos 53 que fueron encontrados en un
remolque en texas manuel acá no tiene la
historia de una de las víctimas que pagó
una cuantiosa tarifa para llegar al
norte del continente
pablo ortega pagó 11 mil dólares por un
viaje exclusivo unos contrabandistas lo
llevarían de méxico a eeuu le prometían
garantías y comodidades para un
recorrido que acabó con la muerte por
asfixia de ortega y decenas de migrantes
más iba pasando un carro por ellos
indirectos 20 años para allá
y hace sin complicaciones y nada de de
que se les atravesara algo en el camino
que todo iba a ser directo le aseguraban
cervezas de cortesía videojuegos e
incluso un cómodo lugar de descanso y
afirmaban que llegaría sin problemas a
florida eeuu para encontrarse con su
madre pero el cuerpo de pablo fue
encontrado en san antonio texas al lado
de 52 más en un remolque de un camión
sin agua ni aire acondicionado
después de arduos trámites para la
repatriación de su cuerpo sus familiares
reunidos en méxico le dan un último
adiós pues a la vez me da me da mucha
felicidad porque él está aquí me da
tristeza porque pues ya no podemos estar
compartiendo dichas cosas que igual
entre todos los amigos siempre
compartimos
si es algo triste su caso hace parte de
un fenómeno cada vez más frecuente a
medida en que se acrecientan los
controles fronterizos para entrar a eeuu
una situación de la que se aprovecha la
industria de contrabando de personas que
generan miles de millones de dólares
pero representa un gran peligro según la
onu los fallecimientos fronterizos
relacionados con vehículos y transporte
crecieron más que cualquier otra causa
de muerte entre 2020 y 2021 y en
argentina la fiscalía empezó a exponer
los alegatos en contra de la
vicepresidenta cristina fernández en el
juicio oral en su contra por presunta
corrupción en un caso de supuesta
asociación ilícita para defraudar al
estado cuando fue gobernante nuestro
corresponsal natalio coso y nos contó
desde buenos aires en qué va el proceso
bueno este es un caso que empezó a
tramitarse judicialmente en 2019 además
de la vicepresidenta cristina fernández
también ex presidenta del país tiene a
otros 12 acusados algunos ex
funcionarios y también el empresario
lázaro báez que ya fue sentenciado en
otra causa por blanqueo lázaro báez es
el empresario se ha señalado en el marco
de esta causa de la que hablamos de
haber estado implementando contratos de
obra pública en la provincia de santa
cruz en la patagonia argentina entre el
año 2003 y 2015 contratos que según la
fiscalía se usaron para desviar el
fondos públicos entre 2003 y 2015 la
presidencia argentina estuvo en manos
primero de néstor kirchner el fallecido
marido de cristina fernández de kirchner
y luego de ella por eso la fiscalía en
fiscal devolución y este lunes en el
primer día de alegatos dijo que hubo una
asociación ilícita encabezada por
quienes se desempeñaron como jefes de
estado por supuesto por ahora todo esto
es presunto según luciano y según la
fiscalía su objetivo era defraudar a
través del desvío de fondos públicos que
debían ir destinados a infraestructura
legal e infraestructura vial perdón y
esto está concentrado en muchísimas
obras es medio centenar de obras
públicas en la provincia de santa cruz
que están señaladas recordemos también
que la provincia de santa cruz fue el
trampolín político de néstor kirchner y
cristina fernández porque allí néstor
kirchner fue gobernador durante muchos
años antes de ser presidente y
actualmente la gobernadora es alicia
kirchner que es hermana de néstor
kirchner y cuñada de cristina fernández
todos los imputados debemos aclarar
niegan los cargos que se le desee que se
les imputan
esto es todo por el momento sigue entre
las 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]